let's go to baltimore maryland where
chase joins us on the line chase how can
we help
hi uh so i'm in high school i'm 16 years
old
i've played for mountain dew high school
and we're a national scene
in football and i play wide receiver and
i have a very good chance to go
to division one level and have a full
ride scholarship to college
but i just started a real estate
business and i make about
anywhere between five to 20k a month
whoa doing
real estate and my father did the
business
and he scaled it up to a million dollar
business a year and i know i can do that
but i don't
i don't have the time and effort because
i only work about two days a week
so i want to see where you guys
depending on this whole situation should
be
my opinion is based on your answers
young man
congratulations first of all on what
you've been able to do
hold on so you're working about eight
days a month and you're making twenty
thousand dollars five to twenty thousand
yeah i i work um mondays and of those
two days i don't go to school
and i work maybe three hours a day yeah
okay so chase
do you want to play division one
football
yeah since i was young and what's the
dream beyond that do you have a dream
for the nfl yeah i've been for nfl and i
have a dream from real estate as well
so yeah but here's the deal here's the
deal you don't have to choose between
the two what if i told you you could
you could pursue both dreams
that would be that would be the best
part okay now here's the catch
you cannot pursue both dreams
at the same pace that's the catch
do you understand what i mean by that
yeah
sure you do so here's the deal you're
already
way ahead of so many young people i mean
you're in the top like point two percent
of young people in the country as far as
just
making income while being in high school
you can continue to grow that business
your dad's got great expertise as you
have laid out
you can hire some really good people to
continue to grow that but if your dream
is to play division one football
you need to go for that and if you want
to take a shot
if your health stays and you got the
prospects and you get to the point
where you're uh you're an actual uh uh
prospect
go for it because if the nfl doesn't
come calling
you've got not a fallback plan you've
got another dream
waiting on you so i i say you pursue
both but understand you're going to have
to be patient on the real estate thing
because you cannot grow it to the level
you want to grow it to until
you can go full time at it but both of
those dreams are
there you're running at both of those
just different paces john
yeah man if you have the opportunity to
go go play football man
i look at it as can't tell me if i'm
wrong here i look at it as
a as a scale if you will you can't
get to be 27 and say man i'm really done
with this
real estate dream it's time for me to go
to college and play football
that does not happen very well you can't
flip it that way yeah you can
get through your sophomore year of
college and realize i don't like the
pressure of d1 football it's a lot
that's
a full-time job it's a life i don't like
it i'm going to roll out of here and go
sell houses
you can do that right absolutely one of
those things you
have to do now or you're cashing it out
the other will continue to be with you
as long as you go
and so man i i say double down and
here's the thing
enjoy your life you're 16 man yeah
you're 16.
real estate's not going anywhere yeah
and chase here's the other thing
i think you trying to grow this thing
while being a full-time student athlete
i think it's going to make you a better
business person for the day when you
actually
retire from sports whether that's in
college if an injury happens which could
happen
or you go it's not for me and i'm tired
of the two a days and you know all the
stuff
i i think if you grow this thing as a
part-timer
to the point that you already have it if
you can keep doing it it's gonna make
you
better because you figured out how to
grow it on a scaled
part-time basis and you you want to talk
about repeatable principles that you're
going to be able to do
man i think you're in great shape so go
play football yeah and enjoy enjoy high
school go play football yeah see what
happens
absolutely